airfares are soaring here's how you can
still get a good deal with summer
airfares already climbing fast airline
executives have not been shy in telling
travelers that prices are only going to
get steeper as we head into spring and
summer delta ceo ed bastian told the
financial times that higher fuel costs
would lead to fair hikes and that the
airline would add a fuel surcharge to
international flights as market
conditions permit according to delta
president glenn howenstein travelers
could expect a 30 to 40 hike on a
round-trip ticket this summer depending
on cost and demand of fuel
but some airfare experts say to be wary
of blaming the higher costs on jet fuel
prices a big portion of the price
increases can be chalked up to typical
seasonal fluctuations and surging demand
according to an economist at hopper
airfares typically rise about seven to
eight percent in january to march
airfares are up 36 since the start of
the year but this could also be because
of surging demand for travel the number
of passengers screened by tsa has risen
85 to 90 percent of 2019 levels a first
since the beginning of the pandemic
another potential factor for rising
ticket prices the pilot shortage
since airlines didn't hire new pilots
during the covet pandemic some weren't
ready for travel to start up again while
jet fuel prices high demand and the
pilot shortage are all conspiring to
drive airfares up this summer there are
also factors that could mitigate that
trend in march jet fuel prices have
dropped more than 6 percent worldwide
and nearly seven percent in north
america according to data from the
international air transport association
if that trend continues airfare should
come down theoretically so if you want
to book on a budget you can find deals
if you plan strategically for one it's
always smart to book as early as
possible the best time to book summer
trips would be right now or by april at
the latest another tip don't watch for
trends watch for deals
there are cheap flights popping up so
subscribe to a flight tracking
newsletter like scott's cheap flights
and keep an eye on those budget airline
websites for your best shot at traveling
for less this year
you